tucker carlson so tiger carlson was was
trending on twitter over the weekend as
he as he often does
only in this case he was trending not
because of anything he said it was a
confrontation between him
and another guy at a fly fishing shop in
montana and i say confrontation really
he talked across it was being accosted
that's not really he was not
this was this was not him confronting
anyone he was apparently at this fly
fishing shop with his daughter
presumably getting some fishing gear
going to go out on a fishing trip with
his with his
and this guy who his name is dan bailey
comes up to him
uh we you can't hear much we'll play the
clip though but this was
originally shared by the leftist account
occupy democrats on twitter in a very
celebratory way
say let's make this go viral and
leftists were cheering this on they love
seeing this
let's watch the clip first and then
we'll talk about it
[Music]
into the united states to everything
else in this world
i don't care that your daughter's here
will you talk to people's families what
you have done
to everybody else in this system
so you can hear him say you can hear him
say there uh that
you're you're the worst human being
known to man
tucker carlson in this guy's mind
and a lot of people on the left would
agree the worst person on earth
is a cable news host who says opinions
you don't like
that's their whole beef with tucker
carlson
they're not they're not alleging that in
in secret he's a he's a
serial killer or something maybe they'll
get to that point eventually but right
now they're not
uh their whole beef is that he has
opinions they don't like
and that makes him the worst person on
earth
you can also hear the guy again his name
is dan bailey apparently you can hear
him say
i don't care if you're with your
daughter
now i got to say maybe i take this
especially personally
because not just as a fan of tucker
carlson but also as a
as an angler myself i i can tell you
this this
this is such a breach in fishing
protocol
to begin with this is
when yeah he's not out at the lake yet
but still you're at a fishing shop
you're thinking about fishing you're
with your kid
you're about to go on a fishing trip
this is a sacred space
fishing the whole thing is a sacred
space including the shops dude go to
bass pro shops sacred
sacred place you don't bring your
personal
feuds and rivalries and politics into
that
uh but that's what he did i i could also
tell you another thing if this guy
is he's according to occupy democrats
he's a fly fishing guide dan bailey
that's part of what he does for a job i
guess
i can guarantee you the leftist vast
majority of the leftists who are
cheering this on
they're not in the market for a fly
fishing guide
in montana
and most of the people who are in a
market for the market for a fly fishing
guide in montana
they don't want some deranged leftist
weirdo who's gonna break them about
politics the whole time
so he's probably just destroyed his
business by doing this and for good
reason
that's the last thing i would want
if i was ever gonna get a fishing guide
which which i probably wouldn't because
a big part of the thing for me is to be
out by myself but um
the last thing i would want is a guy
who's going to be doing that
defeats the entire purpose
but when you see uh the left is cheering
this on
when he's out again out with this kid
minding his own business yeah i i think
you see how
is just no respect this is why i'm
always
beating this drum about we don't have
unity in this country
and we're not going to have unity
okay not anytime soon so
some some massive fundamental things
would need to change in this country in
order for there to be anything like
unity
and those changes if they ever happen
aren't going to happen anytime soon um
and this is one of the reasons why you
see it here why there isn't unity
because there's just no respect
that guy costing tucker carlson has no
respect for him on any level at all as a
man
that's why you go after a guy when he's
with us with his daughter at a fishing
shop
and all the left is cheering it on they
have no respect for him
none i'm not saying they don't respect
his views we know that they don't
respect him as a person
and it's not just him
if you don't agree with them
if you have opinions that differ from
their own especially if you make the
mistake of saying them out loud
they do not respect you as a person and
they don't think you're worthy of
respect
and that's been made really clear
maxine waters remember she said confront
them everywhere you find them make them
make sure they know they're not welcome
and she was talking ostensibly about
people affiliated with the trump
administration but really she was
talking about conservatives
there's no there in order for there to
be some kind of unity there has to also
be
serving as the foundation of that unity
there has to be some kind of elemental
fundamental
respect between the two parties you
can't have unity without respect
i don't agree with you but i but i
respect you as a person
and i have to tell you something it's
not just on their end
i will fully admit i don't respect them
either
if you take someone for example who
would defend a man's right to go into a
woman's locker room and expose himself
to women and children someone who
who takes that position i don't respect
you
someone who defend the mutilation and
drugging of kids
someone who defends the the mass
execution of 60 million unborn babies
i don't i don't respect you it goes way
beyond i disagree i do disagree with you
but i also
i just don't respect you as a person
anymore because of that
this is this goes beyond a mere
disagreement
this is a moral flaw a character flaw on
your part
that is so profound that i don't know
how could i respect you
so it's a it's a mutual feeling i think
on both sides
and not exactly the foundation for unity
there
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content